- I think I'm bad.
Beyoncé is my name.
(piano music)
- [Gary] I think
everything is about balance.
I don't think, you know,
it's just balance.
If you're complaining like the
one thing I want to make sure
everybody hears on the way
to work today is if you make
$41,000 a year, if you make $7 an
hour and you work two jobs and
you have $400,000 in student
loans but you don't complain and
you're not depressed,
you've won.
If I get one person right now on
the Mass Pike to do it
and get that email in
two years than this
10 minutes was accomplished.
Hold on. Hey man.
- Phone's dead or else
I would get a picture.
Nice to meet you man.
Richard.
- Richard, nice to meet you.
Real pleasure.
Your phone's dead?
- Yeah, my phone's dead.
I actually just finished your--
- Brandon, let me call you back.
- your interview on--
- Breakfast Club.
- Breakfast Club Yeah.
- Yeah.
You do you.
I'm not judgin'.
Who the hell am I to judge?
Here's what I'm saying, you
get one life. This is America.
And by the way,
I'm not naïve to females,
race things like that.
It's harder but if there's
anybody on earth it looks like
you that's made it
that means you can too.
I gonna hook you up man.
- Really appreciate it.
- Of course.
What is your email?
- Richard.
- Here, I'll let you put it in.
- What brings you here?
- I have a meeting
with (censored) of Chase.
How about you?
Do you work here?
- Yeah, I work here.
Cool, thank you.
- Real pleasure.
Thanks for saying hello.
Take care.
Hey.
Okay.
I gotta run into a meeting.
I think what I'm good
at is telling you when
when things are important.
So...
Alright, I'm going to go in.
I don't think you
can go up there.
Hey.
- [Man] Are you Gary Vaynerchuk?
- I am.
- Hey Jeremy Erber.
I work for Barclays Center.
- Oh is that right?
- You came and talk to
us couple years ago.
- Yes. Yes.
- I follow some your stuff online.
- Thank you man.
Thanks for saying hello.
All well?
- Yeah.
All's good.
- Thanks for saying hello.
Real good. Running
into a meeting.
- Okay.
- Take care of yourself.
Stay well.
A lot going on, huh?
Yeah. I'll pop out.
Alright? Okay.
Hello.
- [Desk attendant] Hi, sir.
- How are you?
Good.
Here to see (censored).
So far a good day.
Just jamming. Meeting after
meeting. Fun to be with Al Roker.
Great to see you my friend.
How are you?
Doing well?
- You bet.
- Good, I'm glad.
There is a shit
load of people here.
- Ton of people.
- Just a ton of people.
Right India?
Now a national legend but
very much a New York legend.
He was our weatherman
especially for me growing up.
My sister literally texted me
she's like "Oh my God, Al."
And so it was fun.
Going to see my
grandma now on her birthday.
Grandma Esther, it's exciting.
- Thank you for coming.
I know how busy you are.
- [Gary] And just jamming.
Just jamming.
So Jersey, come back,
a bunch more meetings.
Nothing too crazy. Nothing too,
I don't know if we're going to do
a big rant here that's
going to be the whole show.
This could be more of a
day-in-day-out kind of thing.
But I do think looking at the
schedule we'll have to come up
with something smart and
awesome to say to you guys.
Hopefully, I'll get
inspired at some point.
I think I started thinking
I was different,
it was a couple of
different times.
I think I thought I was
different in sixth grade
I remember very
clearly, fifth-grade.
Fifth, sixth grade.
- 11-ish 12-ish.
- Whatever that is.
- Yeah.
- How do you build unbelievable
self-esteem without
creating any entitlement?
I mean, mother
fucker, that's what it is.
That's what it is.
- Yeah.
- I am completely
egotistical about my skills
with zero entitlement.
That's why I have special
results because
I am pointed so opposite.
If you ask me if I give my best
at-bat of dissecting why
I've over indexed or had success
it's because I'm pulling
from the very opposite points
of view and it is creating an
enormous balance.
No one side gets
ahead of the other side.
My ego and my bravado allow me
not to just do the humility,
get the dirt work stuff.
That's why I don't have a
garage sale business.
My lack of entitlement and
humility allow me not to read
the accolades when people say
"I'm the best" or "Top five" or
"the future of this".
I'm like "I don't deserve that.
"I need to earn that."
Yes, I do a daily vlog--
- [Woman] Uh-huh.
- so I'm documenting my
entire life, forever.
If I actually from where I
started go on to buy a
$4 billion sports organization and
I documented the entire journey
my words are motivating
and I'm good at that
but the reason I do DailyVee
and the reason I'm
documenting so much is if I can
put out a body of work 40 years
from now that showed the process
of a young man that
put in the work,
had the vision,
did it the right way,
tried to help people
along the way because he was
trying to build the biggest
building in town by building it
not by tearing everybody
else's buildings down
and then I actually accomplish it
well that becomes a real
great American dream story.
That becomes a movie.
That becomes legacy that
becomes all-time special.
And I'm not going to become a
billionaire overnight like Zucks
or like Sacca or like Travis
but I'm going to get there as a
tortoise which is going to
confuse everybody
because I have a
hare's costume.
Good? Fun meeting?
Bad? Bad? Good. Good.
Good meeting?
- Welcome to summer school.
Got anything to say?
- I hope everybody's doing
super well and happy and super
available if you need me.
(laughter)
Being a good Jersey boy I
watched Al give the weather when
I was six so it's
like super fun.
I'm like "Of course."
I did not follow the script.
(laughter)
- [Tyler] You should cut
across town early, downtown.
- [Gary] What's up guys?
- [Man] How are you?
- [Gary] I didn't listen.
- [Tyler] Should cut
across town early.
- [DRock] Should cut
- And were we getting in a cab?
- [DRock] Uber.
- Kev just said
uptown is more locked.
You should go down
here and then go up.
- Okay. Cool.
- [Tyler] Toyota Camry.
- [Gary] Toyota Camry?
What is the digits?
- [Tyler] Silver. T64.
- T6. Where is he?
- Right outside.
- Talent gets you so far.
Putting in the work.
Lotta people look at
the finished products.
They look at LeBron today.
They look at Kobe today.
They look at Beyoncé today.
You know what's great about
some of the old some of the ways
certain people worked,
Beyoncé's a good play.
Her family wanted, thought that
she would be a star, they would
be stars so there's a lot of
film of them on "Star Search" or
the old video cameras.
But that was work.
And she was a young teenager,
maybe even before
she was a teenager,
she's learning dance moves.
Now people will listen to a song
where she has a lot of bravado
and like "Oh."
It's a lot easier to be somebody
who's got confidence or oomph or
is looking for something
that may seem disproportionate
because they know the
40 years they put into.
- [DRock] Like how do they
get tangled up like that?
- Yeah, this is like
a complete debacle.
No sense.
If I'm sitting on the couch and
I like "Oh, that athlete thinks
they're so fancy," I wasn't
there for the last 22 years that
they woke up at 5 o'clock
in the morning to
get them to this moment.
And that's probably
how I feel a lot.
Which is like I get everybody
should almost especially the way
I communicate and how
competitive I am
almost everybody should be like
"Who do you think you are?"
But I also know why I feel like
I can do that because I only
give advice I take for myself.
I lack any hypocrisy.
I'm telling you things
that I do for myself.
I'm telling you to be patient.
I'm patient.
You're just catching me at 40.
Catch me at 22
when I'm bagging ice.
Catch me at 25 years old when
I've already got stuff going on
and I'm carrying boxes.
Really easy for me to
tell you be patient.
Or anybody.
- [DRock] Yeah. I'm more--
- [Gary] I'm not talking
about or talk about
what we just talked about.
- [DRock] I know.
I'm talking about to anybody.
- [DRock] Anybody.
- Because when I was 27 years
old and already built a big
business and already had a real
success and could've taken a lot
of money off the table I on
December 9th would carry your
box, three boxes of beer to
your car and say thank you
for shopping at the store.
Nothing was below me.
Today, nothing is below me.
You know?
I'm out of here. See you.
Time stamp that.
- She think she fine.
Blow your mind.